if you're looking for the true lead
characters of Star Wars look no further
than c-3po and r2d2 together they're one
of fictions greatest duo's and the real
POV characters of the franchise let's
take a look at the saga from their point
of view r2d2 came from the planet Naboo
where he was one of several nearly
identical astromech droids stationed on
Queen Padme Amidala zoil starship when
the Jedi qui-gon jinn and his apprentice
obi-wan Kenobi helped the queen escape
from captivity during a blockade by the
Trade Federation the starship was fired
upon by ships hoping to recapture
Amidala a bunch of droids including r2d2
exited the ship to make repairs from the
outside whilst several other droids were
blown off the ship and destroyed
artoo survived and made the repairs that
enabled the ship to escape he was
personally thanked by the Queen and from
that point on served her more directly
when Amidala ship stopped on the planet
Tatooine
they met c-3po a protocol droid that
lacked assaulter casing which made him
look like a metal skeleton covered in
wire young anakin skywalker claimed that
he had built c-3po himself
well I c-3po stator banks that already
existed and his body was a wreck and so
Anakin we constructed him from spare
parts
when qui-gon saw Anakin's potential to
become a Jedi he won the boys freedom
from the junk dealer named Watteau who
had enslaved him and his mother Shmi but
she and c-3po were forced to stay behind
when Padme Amidala sturm as queen of
Naboo ended she became a senator r2d2
joined her on Coruscant the Galactic
capital weather Droid helped obi-wan
kenobe and a grown-up Anakin Skywalker
foil an assassination attempt on pomades
life this led Anakin to take her into
hiding of planet bringing r2d2 along but
when Anakin began having visions of his
mother in peril the trio returned to
Tatooine there they were reunited with
c-3po who now had a rusty metal covering
that made him look more like a typical
protocol droid they also learned that
Shmi Skywalker had been freed from
slavery by a man named CLE glass who
became a husband after being freed me
and c-3po moved to the last moistur farm
but Shmi was captured by Tusken Raiders
and died just as Anakin arrived to save
her c-3po departed the last farm with
Anakin and Padme and TN r2d2 accompanied
them to Geonosis
there they found their way into the
foundry where battle droids were built
and c3po s head was swapped with a
battle droid head much says confusion
fortunately r2d2 was able to reunite his
friends head with his body are two and
three Pio escaped their allies but the
clone wars have begun the two droids and
attended a secret wedding of Anakin and
Padme on the bow after six seasons of
the animated series Star Wars the Clone
Wars r2d2 and c3po have had far too many
adventures to recount them all here
suffice it to say that r2d2 usually
accompanied anakin skywalker on missions
while c-3po was more often the companion
of senator Padme Amidala they did have a
few adventures together however such as
when they accompanied Anakin and Padme
to Cato Neimoidia as part of a plan to
expose rush Clovis as a separatist spy
while there Padme was poisoned and
Threepio helped a medical droid see to a
recovery the droids were heroes in their
own rights when they were sent to the
quake ridden planet Aleen as part of a
relief effort when r2 and 3po found
themselves trapped beneath the planet's
surface they discovered a way to stop
the quakes earning the eternal gratitude
of the aleena people in one of their
strangest adventures r2d2 and c3po made
an emergency landing on the planet where
they were tied up by the miniature
inhabitants the tiny people brought them
before their dictator hay-zu but r2d2
accidentally squashed him to the delight
of the other citizens who then helped
the droids repair the ship c-3po
introduce them to the concept of
democracy but it only led to more
fighting as a droid made their escape
there Natsu and Threepio landed on the
planet bow nap which was also ruled by a
dictator
this one turns out to be a hologram
operated by a group of pit droids who
were secretly running the planet
themselves why the closing days of the
Clone Wars r2d2 was Anakin's full-time
co-pilot
while c-3po state with Padme on
Coruscant are to accompany down a kin
and obi-wan Kenobi when they boarded the
flagship of separatist military
commander General Grievous to rescue the
kidnapped Chancellor Palpatine who was
secretly a Sith Lord Arzu even fought
off some super battle droids on his own
showing how much his abilities and
personality
outstripped his programming he joined
Anakin obi-wan and Palpatine on the
bridge as Anakin crushed landed the
flagship on Coruscant
c-3po met up with r2d2 soon thereafter
and the two cuts up on what they missed
while there are parts Anakin Skywalker
soon fell under the sway of Palpatine
and r2d2 was noticeably unsettled by his
master's changing behavior but still
accompanied him to the lava strewn
planet Mustafar
where Palpatine had sent him to kill the
separatist leaders when a distraught
Padme followed Anakin to Mustafa
c-3po piloted a ship himself showing
that he had gained new skills as well
while obi-wan and Anakin fought their
fateful duel the droids helped an
injured and very pregnant Padme back
onto a ship both droids left moves too
far with obi-wan and rendezvous with
Bail Organa of Alderaan
after Padme died and her twin children
Luke and Leia were placed in hiding
Organa gave the toys the captain Ramos
Antilles who commanded his flagship to
protect the twins from Emperor Palpatine
and Anakin who had now fully become
Darth Vader Organa told Antilles to have
c-3po s memory erased c-3po and r2d2
spent most of the time between the end
of the Clone Wars and the Battle of
Yavin serving Captain Antilles on board
his ship the Tantive for which served as
transport for outer rands royal family
and also flew missions for the
burgeoning Rebel Alliance they
occasionally had other duties however
such as when Bail Organa send them to
escort Imperial Minister tua and an
Akhilesh arms dealer named
aMDA Wabo on a mission to the planet
Corral officially c-3po was there to
translate between sewer and Wabo who
liked a shared language but r2d2 knew
their true mission which was to prevent
ture and the Empire from getting their
hands on a shipment of powerful weapons
the two droids were also at the rebel
base on Yavin 4 in the lead-up to the
Battle of scare off' where a suicide
mission by a ragtag group of rebels
enabled the alliance to obtain the
schematics to the planet destroying
Imperial Space Station known as sir
desta unbeknownst to the Empire the
Imperial engineer who had designed the
moon sized weapon and included a
weakness that would enable its
destruction
ultimately the plans for the Death Star
ended up on the 10th of 4 with r2 and
3po aboard which would lead to their
biggest adventure yet
princess leia organa was fleeing from
scare after Tatooine
with the Death Star schematics when
Darth Vader's forces attacked and
boarded the ship c-3po and r2d2 became
the most important droids in the galaxy
when Leia hid the Death Star files and
Artoo's memory banks
c-3po didn't know about the mission
should given r2 but still followed his
friends at the surface of Tatooine how
did we get into this mess we seem to be
made to suffer it's our lot in life on
the desert planet once again the droids
were captured by javis and salts Owen
Lars and his nephew Luke Skywalker r2d2
however was determined to fulfill his
mission for Princess Leia by finding the
exiled Jedi obi-wan Kenobi he succeeded
along with Threepio and Luke of the
imperial search for the droids led to
the murder of Luke's aunt and uncle soon
after the droids Luke and obi-wan
escaped Tatooine on board han solo ship
the Millennium Falcon after rescuing
lair for the Death Star the whole group
arrived a Rebel Alliance headquarters on
Yavin 4 when Luke volunteered to fly an
x-wing fighter in the attack on the
Death Star
r2d2 perform the same function for him
but he had for his father interfacing
with the x-wings astromechs slot to help
the ship fly he took serious damage in
the battle and c-3po even volunteered to
donate parts for his repair but the
rebels grateful to Luke for destroying
the Death Star did an exceptional job of
repairing r2 on their own when the
rebels were forced to flee Yavin for the
ice planet hoth r2d2 and c3po naturally
came along after assisting in the effort
to locate Luke and Han when they went
missing r2 and 3po were forced to
abandon the Hoth base along with the
rest of the rebels when imperial forces
arrived
c-3po left with han and Leia on the
Millennium Falcon while r2d2 left with
Luke in his x-wing when the Millennium
Falcon arrived in Cloud City on the
planet best bin Threepio wandered away
from his friends and was blasted to
pieces by stormtroopers fortunately
those pieces were found by Chewbacca the
tech-savvy wookie copilot of the Falcon
who was able to restore Threepio to
consciousness but didn't have a chance
to fully reassemble him meanwhile r2d2
when with Luke Skywalker to the swamp
planet Dagobah so Luke could train with
the Jedi Master Yoda
whose only role in Luke's Jedi training
was as a way to be lifted with the force
and he spent a lot of time sitting
around waiting
eventually Luke had a vision of his
friends in peril on bespin and TNR too
left to save them there are two in the
disassembled c-3po who reunited once
again as they escaped on the Falcon
artoo helps put his friend back together
unfortunately han Solo had been captured
on bass Ben and taken to the gangster
known as Jabba the Hutt c-3po and r2d2
were part of the mission to rescue Han
Solo from Jabba the Hutt
although as usual Threepio wasn't nearly
as informed about the planners are too
we bring a message to your master
they arrived in Jabba's palace on
Tatooine and r2 played a message from
Luke Skywalker saying that both droids
were gifts for the hurt Threepio was
horrified but he served as Jabba's new
translator while r2 carried a drink tray
on the Hutt Sail Barge eventually the
plan came together and when Luke needed
his lightsaber for the rescue
it turns out r2 deeds who had been
secretly carrying it in a hidden
compartment all along c-3po was much
less help and had one of his eyes poured
out by Jabba's monkey-like companion
salacious crumb 3pa was lucky the arts
who shoved him off to Sail Barge for
fraud exploded and their friends put
them out of the sands before leaving
Tatooine r2d2 took a brief detour with
Luke to return to Dagobah for one last
visit with Yoda before he died of old
age then both droids accompany the
rebels on a mission to the forest moon
of Endor when they encountered the
native population a bunch of teddy
bear-like creatures called a walks the
creatures mistook c-3po for a God with
the help of luke's force abilities
Threepio was able to prevent the
surprisingly vicious ebox from cooking
and eating the rebels and their
cooperation helped the rebels to feed
the Empire after the victory attend or
c-3po continue to serve Princess Leia
and Han Solo as they booted out Imperial
holdouts and restored the Republic on
the first order arose to attempt to
reinstate a galactic empire Leia became
the general of the resistance that
opposed them and Threepio followed her
on a mission for the resistance
c-3po formed an unlikely friendship with
a captured first-order protocol droid
called om r1 one that droids were
trapped on a dangerous planet a tentacle
creature ripped off
three POS left-arm om r1 ultimately
sacrificed himself to save c-3po and
Threepio war is red armed for a time in
memory of his friend because of the red
arm as the r2d2 he stuck by Luke
Skywalker side as Luke built a new Jedi
Temple and attempted to train a new
generation of Jedi unfortunately all of
that was undone by Luke's own nephew Ben
solo who led the mysterious Knights of
Ren in slaughtering the other trainees
and destroying the temple r2 stood with
his master as they watched the temple
burn afterward Luke left r2d2 behind
when he went into hiding and the
exhausted droid entered a low-power mode
that he would maintain for years still
wearing OMR ones red arm c-3po accompany
general Leia Organa on a rescue mission
to the planet takodana back at the
resistance headquarters on the car r2d2
was still in hibernation mode on the
force prodigy Rey arrived and said that
the first order already had found most
of the map to Luke Skywalker's hiding
place except for the part that had been
hidden in young droid bb-8 some parts of
r2 heard what Ray said which brought him
out of his low-power coma r2d2 then
helped bb-8 assemble them up to Luke's
hiding place on the planet octo leaving
c-3po and the car are to accompany Dre
and Chewbacca on the Millennium Falcon
to find Luke when the first-order
uncovered the location of the resistance
base on the car it was c-3po who
received the transmission and informed
Leia that they would have to evacuate he
and Leia and most of the resistance
leadership escaped aboard two starship
rudders as the raddest was pursued by
the first order their bridge was
destroyed by TIE fighters leaving Leia
badly injured
c-3po wanted nothing more than to stay
by her side while she recovered but he
found himself unwillingly involved in a
mutiny led by Poe Dameron against acting
resistance leader Admiral hold oh when
they awoke up and stopped the mutiny
Threepio immediately surrendered
meanwhile r2d2 was on the distant planet
of up to where Rey was doing a poor job
of convincing Luke Skywalker to train
her as a Jedi Luke wanted nothing to do
with teaching birth r2d2 changed his
mind by playing the original recording
of layer that he'd deliver to obi-wan
Kenobi decades earlier
but before Ray's training was complete
she artoo and Chewbacca headed back to
the resistance
after Umrah whole dough sacrificed
herself and the raddest to enable the
other resistance survivors to escape
c-3po fled with Leia and the other sort
of salty planets of crate in the midst
of a devastating attack from the first
order Luke Skywalker surprised everyone
by arriving just in time to engage his
former Protege kylo Ren in combat
c-3po seemed like he might have noticed
something ask you about Luke but he
shuts up about it when Luke winged to
him
sure enough Luke turned out to only be a
force projection and not really uncrate
at all he was merely a distraction to
give the resistance enough time to
escape nevertheless Luke's gambit paid
off and c-3po was reunited with r2d2
aboard the Millennium Falcon when Rey
and Chewbacca arrived to help with the
evacuation in the final days of the war
as a first order became the final order
and Emperor Palpatine rose again r2d2
remained at resistance HQ while c-3po
went on a mission with the galaxy's
greatest heroes to find the hidden safe
planet of Mexico along the way they
found a dagger that contained Sith runes
that would show the way Threepio was
able to read the runes but because they
were sit writing his programming
prevented him from translating them for
his friends in order to complete the
mission they had to go to a tiny droid
smith named Babu Frick who was able to
override the programming in c-3po to
electric brain understanding the odds
well enough to know those sacrifice was
necessary c-3po said goodbye to his
friends and the loudest memory to be
wiped for at least a second time when he
returned to the resistance base r2d2 was
surprised that his best friend didn't
remember him
although the amnesic Threepio was
reluctant at first to let the pushy
astromech droid messed with his head but
he was able to restore his memory
together they celebrated the final
defeat of Palpatine and the first order
just as they were therefore Palpatine's
rise they were around for his fall after
all aren't they the real stars of the
saga check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one